hello YouTube jazz lovers my friends
this is grunge in here and today we are
going to learn how to deal with the
Kings Indian attack now the Kings Indian
attack is very popular in serious
tsunamis the simple reason is the system
from the White is rock solid and very
flexible white can go either on the
crane side and most likely white will go
for the King side attack and the big
plus point is the piece layout of the
white is very much fixed that means you
can learn the theory within one or two
hours and you can start playing in
tournaments now before we move on let me
show you the exact piece layout of the
Kings Indian attacks so the Kings Indian
attack start with this move which is e
for then followed by the moved e3 then
the knight goes to the d2 and the other
night goes to the f3 and after g3 Bishop
to g2 castling on the Queen side and c3
you can see by the arrows a very easy
and a simple plan of the white so if the
black has gone on the Queen side then
white can attack the black on the Queen
side by throwing a and B pawn of the
board and if the black has gone on the
King side then white can simply play
nice to h4 and the F pawn will run down
the board with putting the King in the
corner and this is a very easy
very effective plan of the white
probably you can try in one of your own
game and you will see how easy to play
as a white now the problem from the
black side is if you do not have any
system against the Kings Indian attack
then you might come in serious pressure
specially in tournaments so that's why
it's very important for you to have some
kind of system under your belt for the
Kings in an attack now the system which
I am going to demonstrate today has two
merits first is if you do not have any
system against the Kings Indian attack
then you certainly want to try out this
system and the second big plus point is
if you are a French player and you are
having a difficulty against the Kings
Indian attack then this is a right
opening choice for you so let's start
why place efore and black responds with
the e6 so we are starting with a French
defense more order and after d3 d5
Knight to d2 Knight to f6 Knight to f3
the normal move of the French defence
motor is c5 but here we'll play Knight
to c6 and after g3 we will put our
bishop on a very good square C file
where it can I up to that f2 square
after Bishop to g2
here comes the first twist in the game
because we are going to capture that
epon now if right here foolishly
captured by the knight
so for example light cross II for then
black has a winning position after
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight
then Queen takes Queen and after King
takes Queen black can simply snap up the
f2 pawn and you can see now not only
White has lost the castle ride but black
emerge with a point up so this is a
winning position for black so more
general response over here will be pawn
takes e4 so D cross e for and here we
will play e5 and you see the big mite of
the e5 now this Bishop is looking at his
own pawn the usual line continues with
castling on the Kings side by the Y and
black will do the same and here the most
general response of the white will be c3
now c3 is a dual-purpose move so first
of all you can see the c3 is stopping
the knight movement to the d4 and e4 and
not only that in future if white vicious
white can always look out for the right
time to play b4 so here there is a
golden rule for black whenever white
play c3 black has to respond with the
move a fire and fi is not only stopping
the B form of the white but as you will
see the theory of this opening like
wants to play on the Queen side and fi
is a first step towards it now the
general line continues with the Queen to
e2 by white which has idea of putting
the roof on the open file black response
is pretty much similar so black will
play also Queen to e7 and now if
white has allowed black to push that
porn then Black has a quick Queen side
attack compared to the slow White King
side attack so it's very important why
it has to play here a four but instead
of a four let's see what happens if
white plays a normal-looking move for
example rook to d1 well if the rook to
d1 then very simple answer is Knight to
g4 so attacking the f2 and that means
what has to passively play the route
back to the f1 and white will lose a
very important time and apart from route
to d1 let's say any other moves of the
white will allow work black to expand on
the Queen side so it's very important at
this point why to stop the Queen side
expansion of the black by this move
which is a for and against this we are
going to play this move which is b6 and
now you can see black has created the
first threat of the game by screwing
Queen and roof by putting the bishop on
a6 so white has to respond this now to
give you an illustration how you can
play for a win in this kind of position
I have pick one game for you this game
was played by Susan Polgar in the year
1981 in the European girls championship
Susan was black now chooses opponent
here at this position played Knight to
c4 but before
that let's see the other options of the
white now the more nature looking move
over here looks like rook to d1 but this
is not a good idea for the white because
the very simple answer of the black will
be Bishop to a6 so attacking the cream
and let's say the Queen goes to the even
then after Knight to g4 white is
hard-pressed to meet the f2 drop so
that's why Queen to even is not not at
all good so the more general response
will be c4 but after you see four black
and respond with rook a to d8 and after
v3 which has an idea of playing Bishop
on a long diagonal black and play Bishop
to be 7 and after Bishop to b2
you won't believe but this is a winning
position for black for example I can
start with this move which is night to
achieve for so attacking the f2 so rook
has to come back but after night to be
four you can see the night is coming
towards to d3 and then it will attack
the f2 again so for example if the white
foolishly play here h3 then black and
simply snap of the f2 and after root
cross F 2 black and play Knight to d3 so
not only it's attacking the rook pinned
rook but black knight is also attacking
the bishop and black
we'll enjoy the game from here onwards
so that's why considering all this
Susan's opponent played Knight to c4
here black continues with the bishop to
his six so pinning the night and why
responded with b3 so protecting the
night and now black played before so
it's again attacking the knight so the
wide response is pretty much forced
White has to capture that pawn and then
black Bishop to capture that night and
here let's say if Queen moves
immediately for example Queen moves to
the c2 then black can simply capture
that night and after white recapture not
only White has the crippled pawn but
black has a passer on the e-file and
that will be a great asset and at the
endgame
so very wisely here white played night
to d2 so protecting the night and black
responded with Knight to d7 so idea is
very simple Knight wants to go to the b6
where it attacks the pinned night one
more time so here white responded with
Queen to even and here black responded
with rook F to d8 now instead of root F
to d8
you may be wondering why not Knight to
b6 at this point
well if Knight to d6 has been played at
this point then
but can simply reply with the night
cross night
so not only it's capturing a piece but
it's also attacking the rook and after
see cross b6 white can play this move
which is c4 and that diagonal has been
block and white is doing much better now
so considering all this susan has not
played night to b6 but instead of that
she choose this move which is rook F to
d8 so rook has been put on the same
diagonal of the Queen now her opponent
was desperately trying to get off the
plane so why place rook to even root D
even has a one good married that because
now this Knight is become free but it
has weakened the f2 Square and black
immediately item so shooting plate Queen
to f6 attacking the f2 now here why
responded night to e3 so not only the
pin Knight comes to the e3 and block the
diagonal but this night has a future
idea of coming to either defy or their
file so this night was so strong that
ujin immediately captured at night and
after rook recaptures white plays Knight
to c5 so now you can see three pcs are
eyeing up that juicy d3 square and why
it has to somehow protect that d3 square
here
why responded with Bishop to have fun
and shoes and capture that Bishop and
after why to recapture their Bishop it
looks like white has defended that d3
square but now black plays Queen to e6
so taking advantage of another weakness
this is
sign of a very good player when your
opponent defended one threat the good
players like Susan created another
threat and by doing this they are
provoking
their opponent to make more mistakes and
that is exactly happen in this game
because of this attack fight place the
only attacking row of this game which is
Queen to be 5 so commune to be fire not
only protecting this fall but it also
attacking the knight here Susan
plays the net Knight to d7 and finally
wide develop the bishop with Bishop to a
6 and now because this Bishop has been
moved from the c1 and then this night
has become weakened black played a very
excellent move which is Knight to f6 now
this move is a very dual-purpose move
first of all it creates a discover
attack to the night and not only that
you can see by the arrows the very
simple and effective plan of the black
so black might wants to play Queen to h3
and then Knight to g4 which all leads to
mate black on h2 so after a long
thinking oh I responded with route to e2
so protecting the night and here black
responded with group to b8 so attacking
the Queen now white played Queen to e5
right now pause for a moment because you
can see this Queen is so far away from
this King
and this is a right time to attack or
your switch the attack to the Kings side
and that is exactly did by the black so
here she was in responded with h5 her
opponent responded with King to g2 so
white desperately wants to stop Queen to
h3 but nevertheless h4 occurs and please
note G cross h4 will be very very
dangerous because a simple line can
drawn like this
so Queen check and after King to have
fun black can play this wonderful move
which is night to h5 although this
Knight is hanging right now black has a
very cunning idea so for example if
white capture this night then after
Knight to f5 attacking the rook f3 by
white and a simple line runs like this
so Queen h3 check King to e1 Queen takes
h4 check King to d1 and then Knight
takes rook King takes Knight and after
queen cross H 2 comes with the chair you
can see black will emerge with an
exchange up and a good position so
that's why G cross s4 will be highly
risky that's why her opponent here
played f3
and black responded with rook to d3 so
attacking the c3 pawn white defended
with rook to c1 and now the last rogue
will join in to the attack so rook to d8
so attacking the knight and the knight
drawbacks to their fun here
one point will be exchanged so H cross
g3 H cross g3 and black responded with
nice to h4 white plays Bishop to c5
which has a merit of controlling all
this dark spares but the downside is
White has a loud black to play this move
which is Queen to g6 and now you can see
the fourth threat is looming so white
has to play this move which is king - f
- who but here again black responded
with very energetically and played rook
to d1 so attacking the rook and probably
Susan's opponent was in time trouble
she played this disaster move which is
rook to e1 and I give you a few seconds
can you find a winning move over here
for the black
and the winning move is rope to d2 plus
and suddenly white is lost
let's see how let's see the white option
not if the King goes to the e3 then a
very simple will be Queen g5 + and after
f5 e cross f5 and if the King goes to
the f3 then very simple will be Knight
to e5 checkmate and if G cross F 4 then
after Queen cross F for this is
checkmate as well
so King to e3 is a disaster zone for the
white what happens if King goes to the
g1
so if the King goes to the g1 then the
very simple reply of the black will be
night cross g3 and you can analyze by
your own all the lines leads to the mate
so that is not good either
and the last reply which has been played
in the game Susan's opponent capture
that rook so night cross d2 but the very
simple repetition is queen cross g3
check and after King to e2 Queen cross
even comes with the check and after King
to d3 route cross t2 and King to c4
Queen to e2 is a checkmate
so this is very wonderful game played by
the Shushan which teaches how to play
for the win in the system I hope you
learn and enjoy this system against the
Kings in an attack please feel free to
comment on my video and I'll meet you
soon bye